I've never seen the show before but
there I was a couple hours ago in the
movie theater watching Glee Glee the 3d
concert now Glee the 3d concert is
exactly what it sounds like it's a 3d
concert of Glee all the actors from the
TV show are playing their characters and
they're up on stage and they're putting
on a concert for everyone play what I
imagine what the favorites from the show
so like I said I've never seen this show
before so I went into this movie going
alright it for nothing else I love music
I'm gonna hear some catchy nazhde
be it's like famous for that the movie
theater sound was just cranked up must
have been the speakers are just blast in
my ears the music's all around II hear
the crowd it's tapping the music starts
off really strong with that hold don't
stop believin song that's like the
staple Glee song I heard it everywhere
when they were talking about the pilot
before there it's always like alright I
like that song they're doing it well I'm
in know as the show starts off strong
with the music the music for me kind of
slows down it's never as good as that
first song it's still catchy yeah my
foot was still tapping but you know
however there are some hot chicks on
Glee seriously this is one chick named
Britney she sings Britney I'm gonna be
serious that was a really hot segment I
was feeling a lot of young kids are
gonna watch that and they're gonna walk
out of the movie theater finding that
their voices are a little lower that day
yeah it was crazy and then it cuts to
fans of Glee and they start interviewing
them and they start talking about why
they like Glee and I was like they're
gonna do this whole thing it's gonna
take away from the concert get back to
the concert I want to hear the music the
coolest part is they're usually like
teenagers and girls and whatnot they're
talking about how they like Glee but
their favorite character is this one 45
year old guys that you know goatee black
and gray hair he's all like I like Glee
I was like yes thank you dude thank you
for being here makes me feel less creepy
right now but that was before I found
the most interesting thing about this
movie and it wasn't really the music it
was the story in the connection that
Glee has with its audience I didn't know
there was like this whole following of
Glee it's like a community now YouTube
has its youtube community there is like
a Glee community and people start
talking about how they're different in
one way shape or form and these real
people in the world always kept what was
different about them inside they were
like ashamed of it they didn't tell
anyone it just made them insecure and
Glee's all about if you're different
cool be proud of it and these people
found strength and confidence in
themselves by watching the show Glee and
if a show can do that I got nothing bad
to say about it I mean I watch a
plethora of shows there all sorts of
shows I watch I don't think any show
that I watch can ever boast that it
helps people go through life with
confidence and who they are word of
advice if anyone's like you know what I
found
FinCEN who I am by watching my favorite
show Dexter run just run so I like the
lesson that the movie convey which I
imagine is the same as what the show
conveys tyrion lanister in the show Game
of Thrones he actually said something
similar I forgot the exact phrasing but
it was something like where who you are
in your chest and you can never be used
a hedge or something like that basically
take who you are wear it on your chest
wear it loudly wear it proudly and if
anyone tries to give you for it
it'll just be ineffective and I'll have
no power whatsoever
this movie promotes that if therefore I
like this movie and yeah the music was
catchy to some songs more than others
but it sounded great leave the 3d
concert was like an American Idol finale
if they had a much bigger budget and a
lot more people involved in it yeah
pretty much so if you like catchy music
I'm talking to you abot gold you'll
probably have a good time with Glee the
3d concert I gotta say it's a good time
no alcohol required for the music the
lesson behind it and a connection Glee
has with its audience so have you seen
Glee do you like it do you watch it I'm
actually asking for my own selfish
reasons I want to know about the show
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]